[Music]
let's talk about Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles - hey where you get back to my
sexuality which you seem to be obsessed
with you you worked with Will Arnett who
who's a friend friend of ours good
friend of Andy's they're practically
roommates and will is a really funny guy
we've known him a long time and it must
be fun working with him yeah he's super
funny he's exactly like you would
anticipate his only he's very
professional I have a story that I like
to tell about him I mean no I don't mean
that in a bad way I mean like you knew I
think he would be joking around while
we're rolling and he's not he's like
focused and doing what he's supposed to
do um but I I have this story about him
that I tell sometimes which he doesn't
appreciate which is on the first turtles
so he doesn't want you to tell this
that's Ben Chang he go put this right up
here you must know that we get to it so
during the first turtles he was sort of
dating a lot and and like every other
week there was a new girlfriend and he
would bring them to set and they were
progressively getting younger and
younger as the week's went on and it got
to the point where I was like buddy
I'm worried should I talk to craft
service and make sure they have
Lunchables
[Laughter]
that's irritating
you